the kaiapoi west regeneration area of
approximately two point six hectares
comprises a rectangular block of land
bounded by raven key and hilton street
to the north and south and by rich
street and black street to the west and
east murphy park and a kaiapoi river lie
to the north of the area traveling in a
southwesterly direction from the
mandeville footbridge across the area
the first part of the area has been
identified as suitable for business use
which could include vehicle parking or
yard based activities such as a plant
nursery or a car sales yard the land in
the second part of the area which is
bisected by the Dudley drain we're
planting enhancement as proposed has
been identified as suitable for a sport
and recreation reserve users could be a
lawn based sports club or overflow
parking venir by Murphy park or a
playground area or a turf area for
informal ball play or the installation
of paths seating and planting we'd like
your comments on these regeneration area
proposals for full details of all the
options outlined in let's plan or to
comment on the plan visit the council
website at Waimakariri govt TN z or red
zone plan ends it will pick up a copy
from any council service center or
library